the Joe Rogan experience dude it's here
we're just a couple days away here we
are
Thursday we got Friday and then
Saturday's fights and I gotta go I'm
gonna be in Jacksonville Florida I'm
gonna be doing commentary in an empty
arena no one's gonna be even near me
everybody has to be really far away from
each other we're gonna be on separate
corners of the Octagon which is which
[ __ ] sucks UDC and hanok and then it
this is when things go crazy DC and I
always grab each other alone
you guys vibe off of each other can't do
that everybody's a [ __ ] but we're all
tested that's what doesn't make me
that's what I'm saying if you all agree
like it will risk him and we're all
healthy we're all fine well not only we
all healthy and fine we're tested we're
for clean we don't have it it's not like
we don't have to be far apart from each
other I got tested yesterday I got the
results back from my nose swab that's
negative and then two days before that I
took an antibody test that's negative
two I'm 100% negative so whose idea is
this it's [ __ ] in the state the state
just has real rigid guidelines
apparently they just want to make sure
that everybody's safe cam Hanes wanted
to come with me he couldn't come
can't we play em in nope nope do you
know what can we do - Kovach doesn't
have a chance
that kind of cardio God come on man
listen I had a lot on the podcast
yesterday and we talked about what the
actual death rate is versus what
everyone thought it was going to be see
good at reading stat as I said it's a
magnitude of 10 to 50 percent 10 to 50
times less deadly than they thought it
was going to be that's a pretty big
change especially when they start
getting to things like I don't know if
you've seen the there's a prison where
they tested these prisoners ninety-eight
percent of them had it and I had no idea
asymptomatic yep yeah everybody was fine
yeah they're finding that in a lot of
places a lot of people are asymptomatic
and elon goes hard in the paint - yeah
which I love he said if you got bit by a
shark and got and died and you had Cova
they would count it as a Kovac death
yeah hundred percent I mean it's
probably making a joke he is but he's
not yeah but he's not yeah yeah he's not
yeah it's so it's so ridiculous man did
we find out whether or not that's true
about the heart attacks the heart
disease because some
else brought it up to me today someone
else who's a pretty smart person in New
York I looked like I couldn't even find
the numbers so I don't know where they
got those numbers see if there's an
article cites part I looked hard is the
pocket is the podcast out I looked hard
sorry is the podcast out yeah
does he mention how in it weird that the
the death rate went down once the flu
season is over do you talk about that
how they're counting flu it's kovat -
yeah that's the thing if you have flu
and kovat they counted as covered
yeah and then the flu you know look cope
it's not good but it's not what we were
worried about it's not what we thought
it was going to be shouldn't shut down
the economy no I don't think so I think
shutting it down for a couple weeks is
not a bad idea to get a sense of it but
once the numbers are back I mean I think
right now it needs to restart people
need to be precautious they need to
follow social distancing guidelines wear
masks if possible especially until we
get it all wrapped up and figure out
what it is and in terms of like what the
treatment like they have what is that
stuff calling in remin bender beer was a
beer
REM des aveer this new antiviral
treatment that they say is supposed to
work we're working really well with it I
think you have underlying health
conditions yeah and you're over 60 put
on a mask if you don't it should be up
to me if I want to wear it did you know
that the average age of Cova death users
or people who get kovat and died is
higher than the average age of death
that's nuts
that's nuts I'm so glad Ellen came on is
that a crazy drop some [ __ ] novel
it's a crazy number you know in it
there's this weird like toxic culture
who wanted to be bad so when he wants
spit these facts I'm sure your podcast
comes out P right no and they start
throwing other facts like no dude these
are the stats yeah it's tough to argue
with these hard cold facts well you want
some not a doctor again save it dude
yeah we're looking at stats yeah I think
you can read stats yeah the deuce thing
get us to the [ __ ] tomorrow so you
can build a [ __ ] planet you know I
think we I think we're gonna be all
right you can read those imma listen at
that guy yeah it's not what we thought
it was gonna be that's what it is
everybody was scared two months ago
holy [ __ ] the plagues coming and it's
not that it's not that we got lucky it's
a bad call
it's really bad kill some people it
[ __ ] people up with respiratory disease
it's really bad for people that are
obese it's really bad for everything's
bad for old people
obese people though everything's bad
that's that's reality that's giving
shape man god damn it say it say it
freakin shape join the big boys bike
club man
[Applause]